Du sa ju att du hade 250 000 besökare i månaden.
Det är ju galet mycket.
Då vill jag nästan med den snällaste formen av mening varför är ni inte ännu större?
Och är det att ni missar att sälja?
Det är ju sjukt mycket folk.
Make Sweden Stronger.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Vad sa du, omsökt 160 miljoner?
Jag är ju chanobilgenerationen, jag är ju...
Kan du inte ta...
Du vet, vem du är typ.
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Ni har inga sura kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig, och det finns inga tre ögonblickar.
Ja, nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men...
Alltså man tar det positivt.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag så har vi Elin Oresten i podden, och det är hon som har grundat och är vd för bolaget Knatterplock.
Ett bolag som egentligen började på Instagram med en matdagbok skulle man kunna säga, men som växte och fick en väldigt snabb tillväxt och en stor följarskara som tittade in när Elin körde sin modell, det kanske är en större modell, men en del av en modell kring hur man ska äta och få barn att faktiskt äta.
Något som alla vi som är småföräldrar vet om.
Sedan har det växt in till ett bolag som vi kommer att få höra mer om.
Jag kan också lägga till att jag brukar berätta för min flickvän vem jag ska intervjua.
När jag berättade att det var just knatterplock så sa min flickvän att det var inte du som upptäckte det företaget, det var jag som upptäckte det företaget först.
Bara så att du vet.
Det stämmer väl, då säger vi hej till Elin.
Hej.
Välkommen till podden.
Vilken härlig signering, tack.
Ja.
Tack så mycket.
Det är första signeringen jag gör, jag har aldrig gjort någon innan, men jag har fått feedback att kan du inte göra det så man vet vem man har där framför.
Vi testar.
Ja, men det är inte alla som vet faktiskt.
Men jättekul att din flickvän vet.
Ja, jag tänker att är man i den här kundgruppen då har man ju högst troligen haft samma problem.
Då har man varit runt och kikat om man inte har matats på Instagram med förslag.
Då har säkert din kanal kommit upp som förslag.
Kan du berätta lite grann bara?
Jag tänker att det är lite svårt att förstå om man inte själv har varit inne och kollat.
Kan du bara förklara lite vad det var du började med och vad det har blivit?
Jag tycker att du summerade det ganska bra där.
Det började faktiskt som en matlagbok på Instagram.
Jag siktade väldigt kul med min dotters mat när hon började äta.
Jag ville helt enkelt bara summera och dela med mig av allt jag lärde mig.
Då startade jag Knatterplock, Instagramkontot, och gjorde det som en matlagbok.
Jag svar inte till någon att jag startade det.
Jag vet inte om jag lite grann skämdes på något sätt.
Jag vet inte vem jag ska starta ett Instagramkonto.
Men på den vägen var det.
Och sen rullade det på.
Jag delade med mig en recept som jag visade när hon åt.
Väldigt simpelt.
Vad var det för recept?
För det fanns ändå någon sorts logik bakom.
Det var inte så att du ballade upp.
Idag har jag gjort falukorv.
Idag har jag gjort pannkakor.
Nej.
Nej men så här.
Min dotter ville egentligen inte bli matad.
Vi försökte med det i början.
Hon ville typ inte öppna munnen.
Och då hade jag också redan börjat läsa den här plockmat, som är mat som barn kan äta självständigt väldigt tidigt.
Det är också ibland kallat för BLV eller baby led weaning på engelska, som man kan säga är en modell eller en metod.
Och då började jag läsa på om det, vilket innebär att hon fick börja äta själv helt enkelt.
Jag lade fram mat som hon själv fick äta, men jag matade den inte.
Och det här tyckte jag var så fascinerande.
Och bara se hur hon tog sig an maten.
Och faktiskt att det gick jättebra för en liten bebis att äta själv.
Man behöver inte mata.
Och jag var ändå låg över det och ville genomöma det.
Så det är konceptet på Instagram.
Just det här med plockmat, BLV.
Den metoden, eller vad man ska säga.
Skiljer det sig från vanligt, om vi säger till exempel potatismos, är det bara att man ska lägga fram potatismos istället för att mata med potatismos?
Är det så det funkar?
Ja, precis.
Det behöver inte vara så här matyta.
Man kan ju låta barnet sitta och kladda den här på potatismos också.
Det handlar ju mer om ett självständigt ätande, skulle jag säga.
Man kan ju också ladda en sked med mat och räcka över den till barnet, som barnen får ta till munnen själv.
Så det behöver inte vara så här fingermat, utan det kan vara andra konsistenser också, vilket är bra för barn behöver lära sig alla olika konsistenser, även de här kletiga och ringiga konsistenserna.
Och sen BLV, jag är inte jättefan av metoder i det perspektivet, för jag tycker det kan bli lite så här, då måste de alltid äta själva och det är jätteviktigt, man blir nästan helt obstinat i det där.
Jag är här förspråkare att följa barnet, och ibland kanske barnet har att äta själv, ibland kanske barnet vill bli matad, och då är det ju helt fajn, sen finns det inget fel på det.
Men mitt konto finns till för att inspirera kring blockmat, just att servera mat som barn kan äta själva tidigt.
Men också kring maktglädje i stort, så har det ju blivit också.
När min dotter blivit äldre och så där, så har det blivit en naturlig utveckling åt det hållet.
Men någonstans där på resan, när du såg att det inte bara är 20 personer som följer Instagramkontot, det är fler människor, då började du ett bolag.
Eller kan du berätta hur processen där gick till?
Nej men först var det bara matavgåk, och jag bara uppgänglade för min inas skull, för jag tyckte det var kul.
Sen märkte jag att det kom in en massa följare.
Första följaren jag fick, då var jag såhär, vem är det här känner jag den här personen?
Det gick in en ståka och jag var såhär, vem är det här?
Men då var det bara någon random som riktade mig i utforskadela.
Och sen så fick jag tid till att följa den första månaden.
Oj.
Det bara rassla in och det var jättespännande och jätteroligt.
Det gjorde jag till att jag blev så sporrad.
Och jag insåg också att det här är verkligen någonting.
För jag tror att jag var det första svenska kontot som pratade om de här delarna.
Just med BlockMato och BLV i viss mån.
Så många förändrar som hade börjat ge BlockMato att det ändå har vuxit.
Jag har funnit Facebookgruppen länge där många delar med sig av vad de ger.
Information, fakta, tips om BlockMato.
Men det har inte funnits så mycket på Instagram på svenska.
Så jag tror att det kom som helt rätt i tiden.
Och sen fick jag mycket frågor om vart är Bonnys tallrik ifrån, vart är Bonnys förkläder ifrån och så.
Och så berättade jag det här min man, som är väl typ såhär entreprenörsgärna.
Det är inte jag kan jag säga.
Men vad då, vad frågar du om?
Ja men tallrikarna blir sticka.
Jaha, vadå, vadå.
Han blir helt såhär.
Men han gick ju igång direkt, jag faktiskt inte är så.
Men sen då kom han med idén.
Han frågade om vi inte tar fram produkter för det här.
Om det finns någon stor efterfrågan.
Och det här verkligen verkar vara någonting som folk är inserierade av.
Ja, på den vägen var det.
Då startade vi webbhoppen ihop sen faktiskt.
För att han är både fotograf och duktig på att bygga hemsidor.
Så då sa han såhär, men är det inte du som får fixa produkterna så fixar jag hemsidan.
Och jag fick fixa marknadsföringar också.
Så vi hade en bra uppdelning där och kom igång ganska snabbt ändå.
Vi bestämde att vi skulle ha ett litet sortiment och bara testa först.
Och se hur det går.
Så då gjorde vi så.
Han byggde hemsidan, jag fixade produkterna.
Och ja, så bestämde vi oss hur vi hade testat.
Vi lanserade faktiskt på internationella kvinnodagen, så det var 8 mars kommer jag ihåg.
Och jag startade kontat 18 november, året innan där.
Så det var ju inte ens ett halvår senare.
Det var väldigt snabbt.
Hur löste ni vilka produkter ni skulle ha då?
Vad ni skulle sätta igång med?
Vem fick ni tag på?
Ja, jag hade ju testat en del produkter redan.
För jag tyckte att det var väldigt roligt att hitta roliga produkter till dotten.
Och jag visste ju inte vad jag gillade eller inte gillade.
Så då började jag leta efter producenter som gör sådana här till exempel siliconprodukter, typ muggar och tallrikar, och tog kontakt med dem.
Och då i början var det lättast att köra med den här off-the-shelf-grejen eller white label-produkter för att testa produkterna på marknaden.
Då valde jag vilken kvalitet på materialet och färger och så vidare.
Sedan köpte jag det hem och testade det.
Då var det mycket sådana produkter men nu har vi nästan inga sådana produkter i shoppen.
Så vi har gjort en resa där men det var ett bra sätt för att testa om det fanns en efterfrågan.
För det gick ju snart.
Men tänkte du att det skulle bli, för ni har ju verkligen vuxit fort.
Förra året gick en fyrdubblan i väl egentligen.
Ni gick upp till 8 miljoner från 2 tror jag.
Så det är en extremt snabb tillväxt och även som du säger, det tog ett halvår från att vi startade konto till att vi drog igång bolaget.
Har ni liksom bara kört på eller har ni tänkt att det här kan bli ett bolag?
Ja, vi har kört på väldigt mycket.
Och jag har absolut inte tänkt från början att det skulle bli ett bolag.
Men med tiden så tror jag att vi insåg att det här kan verkligen bli någonting stort.
Och jag tror att första AHA-upplevelsen var väl på lanseringsdagen.
För då, vi hade ju köpt in ett lager på produkterna, några stycken, och sen sålde vi slut typ, alltså, kanske efter två timmar från lansering.
Lävligt.
Så då var det såhär, okej, ja.
Och då var det ju lite tråkigt för att det är ju liksom ledtider hela tiden när man köper in, du vet ju du, som också har nerehandel.
Då hade vi ingenting att sälja.
Jag tog resterande tid två, tre månader efter det.
Så första året var egentligen bara ett halvt år för oss.
Men så då var det verkligen såhär, ja, det här finns ju rätt frågan, det här kan verkligen bli något.
Och då vågade vi också satsa.
Och då kom jag i kontakt med en kvinna som jag jobbat med tidigare, som jobbar med professionella investeringar.
Och då berättade jag för henne om vad vi hade gjort och vad vi hade tänkt oss.
Så då fick vi vår första investering där efter lanseringen.
Och kunde på det sättet växa ganska snabbt.
För att vi visste att det finns rätt frågan, då kan vi liksom, nu vågar vi köpa på oss.
Var det hon som köpte in sig idag?
Ja, precis.
Hon gick in.
Hon litade på er?
Hon litade på oss.
Vi hade jobbat ihop och jag tror att hon vet lite hur jag är.
Så då tror jag att hon litade på oss.
Och hon trodde också väldigt mycket på affärsideen i sig.
Så hon är kvar än och hon är nog glad att hon gick in tror jag.
Hoppas jag eller så.
Är hon den enda investeraren eller har ni tagit in den nu för er?
Nej, vi har faktiskt tagit in några till.
Vi tog in en till där i samma veva faktiskt.
En annan bekant och sen har vi gjort en andra runda förra året.
När vi tog in lite mer pengar till.
Det har vi inte tagit in för mycket men lite till.
Så vi har väl ett kraftdiv på kanske 5 personer totalt sett.
Varför valde ni, för ni har ingen verksamhet som blöder massa pengar, varför valde ni att inte bara lösa lån?
Lösa lån, vi har faktiskt kollat på den möjligheten och det är svårt att lösa lån om man inte har en omsättning, man kanske inte har en lösam verksamhet riktigt än, på det sättet som banken vill se.
Så det är svårt och sen så, det är klart att få man ett erbjudande där precis när man är helt ny och har startat någonting, så är det svårt att tacka nej.
Och jag ville också ha in kompetens i företaget, och det fick jag med Hennedorf som gick in då.
För oss har det varit väldigt värt, men däremot har vi sagt nu att vi inte ska ta in pengar förrän vi verkligen behöver det framöver.
Men jag tror att däremot har det varit av oss faktiskt för att vi kunde växa och göra det så snabbt som vi har gjort.
Jag är ändå glad över det.
Att det inte blev ett banklån.
Men nu skulle vi behöva pengar i allt, så kanske vi mer skulle kolla på ett lån skulle jag säga.
Jag förstår.
Du sa att din man hade lite entreprenörstjänare, men du är kostrådgivare från början.
Nej, jag är faktiskt civilingenjör från början.
Jaha, okej.
Jag har gjort helt andra saker innan.
Jag läste en kandidat i produktverkling, sen så har jag läst management masters.
Och efter det så har jag jobbat som management consult i typ sex år.
Och jobbat mycket med energibranschen och så.
Så jag har jobbat mycket med andra saker, men mycket med affärsutveckling och ledning och så.
Men jag har väl inte känt riktigt att det är det jag brinner för.
Och jag har alltid sagt till min man att jag vill jobba med makt och hälsa och kost och sådana saker.
Så jag har kollat mycket på det artistprogrammet innan, men jag har känt att jag inte har varit jättesugen på fem år till i skobänken.
Så då när jag blev mammaledig så gjorde jag väl en sån här klassisk livskredsgrej.
Vad ska jag göra med mitt liv?
Så då blogger jag till konstruktivare under mammaledigheten.
Det känns väldigt klassiskt.
Jag tänker att antingen startar man företag då eller så får man starta företag innan, men det är svårt att starta företag efter.
Ja, precis.
Efter exakt.
Nej, det gör man kanske inte.
Men idag jobbar ni båda två heltid här?
Ja, det gör vi faktiskt.
Det har också varit en lite krokig väg.
Jag är ingen typinärskväll på det sättet, men jag är lite så här, jag är inte så riskbenögen av mig, men det är något som tycker jag är väldigt kul.
När man har startat upp grej så älskar jag att driva på, utveckla och köra på.
Det är liksom min grej.
Min man kanske är mer stark på det första, att starta olika saker.
Men han har gjort lite olika saker, men han har varit fotograf, och sen under pandemin så gick det inte bra för fotografer i olika skäl.
Så då skickade han sig på sin andra dröm i livet, förutom att vara entreprenör och fotograf, att bli polis.
Så då pluggade han till polis, men han hjälpte mig eller tiden att bygga upp web-shoppen och allt det där.
Men sen när han såg vad som hände med Katiplocka och var där på väg, då var han såhär, ja det här är också min dröm att vi ska entreprenella.
Så då jobbade han som polis i ett halvår efter sin aspirant och sen började han plugga med mig istället.
Världens kortaste sejor inom polisen.
Verkligen.
Det är lite komiskt, men han har alltid testat på den grejen.
Det har alltid varit en dröm som sagt att jag tror att han är nöjd med det.
Jag tänker när ni tar fram produkter för barn, för du sa att från början var det mycket white label, men nu kanske ni är med lite mer i produktutvecklingen.
Hur skiljer det sig jämfört med, till exempel när jag tar fram en hantel, säger jag ju typ, kär jag vill ha en hantel, det här är prispointen.
Jag gissar att ni har en lite krångligare process.
Jag tänker att dessutom kommer folk ha mycket åsikter och de kommer ha åsikter även om det är en bra produkt.
De kommer att fråga tusen miljoner frågor.
Hur gör man för att det ska bli rätt?
Oj, svår fråga.
Det är en svår bransch på ett sätt.
Det är en känslig målgrupp.
Det är barn, man vill ju att de ska vara säkra och ha bra produkter.
Det får ju inte gå fel.
Nej, precis.
Så är det ju.
Sen så finns det ju regelverk också att hålla sig till.
Sen har man ju föräldrarna som också såklart vill det bästa för deras barn.
Det förstår jag skönt ut.
Många föräldrar är också väldigt engagerade i de här frågorna.
Det är väldigt högt engagemang.
Men när vi tar fram produkten nu så är det lite olika.
Ibland så kommer vi på en idé och då är det såhär.
Och så finns det inget liknande.
Då får man börja från början.
Då kan vi antingen jobba med en designbyrå i Stockholm där vi kollar på det ihop och försöker ta fram någonting.
Eller så kan man jobba direkt med producenterna.
Men det är inte alltid det lättaste.
Utan då ska man vara med producenten direkt då ska det nästan finnas listan.
Den här typprodukten tänker vi oss fast lite olika justeringar.
Så det är lite olika hur processen går till beroende på vad det är för någonting.
Men vi har tagit ett aktivt beslut att inte köpa rena white label-produkter längre.
Vi vill vara en rika och det finns ofta väldigt mycket saker vi vill ändra och göra så att det passar vår målgrupp bäst.
Vi tror väldigt mycket på funktion och det kräver ofta om man gör lite justeringar.
Vi har tagit det som ett aktivt val.
Jag tycker att det går igen lite när man kollar på era produkter så känns det ändå som att det är en serie.
Det känns inte som att det är fyra olika modeller av grejer eller fyra olika producenter, utan det känns som att det är ett färgspråk och det är en viss tjänst.
Den känns ganska mjuk liksom.
Så det känns lite barn eller bebisaktigt eller vad man ska kalla det.
Och det känns ganska naturligt.
Det ser liksom, det känns inte så industriellt.
Det känns ju som att ni har lyckats där.
Ja men det är glad att du säger så.
Men det har också varit en, vi har ju också bara funderat på vägen, vilka är vi och vad ska vi ha, hur ska vi se ut och hela den grejen.
Och jag tror att mycket hände när jag förra året anställde en tjej som blev chef för design med någon som chef för marknad.
Och då tog vi varumärket till en ny nivå.
Och efter det så tycker jag att det blir mycket mer streamlinat och väldigt mjukt och du känns enhetligt på att te på en annan sätt än vad du har gjort innan.
Det gör mig jätteglad att det blir så.
Är det en producent som löser alltihopa eller måste ni gå till flera?
Vi har flera.
Vi har för många, helt ärligt.
Är det så?
Det känns ändå som att det går under samma kategori?
Ja, nej, jag vet inte vad som hände.
Men i ärlighetens namn har vi alldeles så många.
Men vi försöker faktiskt jobba med att försöka ta ner antal producenter.
Vissa är vi inte nöjda med så då försöker man plitta.
Men det är svårt också för när man tar fram egna, jag vet inte hur det funkar i din bransch, men man njuter ju produkterna i olika former.
Och så har man liksom investerat i en form och så där, och så är det liksom alltid såhär superlätt att flytta den med alla producenter och så.
Så att ja, det är många men vi försöker hela tiden att, alltså vi har nog samma färger, vi har nog samma material, vi försöker se den se likadant ut, så folk precis som syns ju inte det.
Hur fick ni tag på producenterna och vart finns de?
Det är enligt spännande.
Ja, nej men vi handlar alltså med Kina främst.
Det är, alltså de är de bästa, säger vad man vill om Kina, men de är faktiskt de bästa i silikonprodukter.
Vi har försökt att slitta vissa delar till Europa, men det är jättesvårt för de har liksom inte den portföljen riktigt här när det gäller silikonprodukter, utan då får man lämna sig till industritillverkare som gör sig andra silikongrejer.
Och då pratar vi om en jättestor investering på att de ska göra våra sorters produkter.
Så vi handlar med Kina.
Och från början, alltså precis i början så hittar vi dem via plattformen Alibaba, som är liksom en plattform där, det är inte Aliexpress som många tänker på, men det är en sisterplattform, där man hittar olika producenter i Asien, som displayar sin produktkatalog, så kan man chatta med dem.
Så det var liksom första sättet att hitta dem.
Sen har man hittat på andra sätt, när man kommer in i branschen, man kanske hör om någon eller man får något mail eller så där.
Det har gått den vägen.
Är det spännande, har ni varit där och kikat eller?
Nej, faktiskt inte la eller så att åka dit.
Vi har haft digitala rundturer men inte åkt dit.
Jag har varit trugen på att göra det men det är inte helt lätt.
Jag förstår.
Du har en ettåring och en treåring idag.
Två små barn och allt.
Man vill helst inte åka iväg i två veckor.
Nej, det gäller bara resa men förhoppningsvis kan vi göra det.
Vi jobbar ju också med Kina såklart väldigt mycket.
Rent personligen, efter att jag har varit där och verkligen träffat producenterna på plats och käkat middag och träffat familjerna och gått runt så blir det mycket personligare.
Man får lite extra hjälp och de är lite mer...
Man visar att man är seriös och då orkar de lägga den tiden.
När den dagen kommer om åtta år när barnen har växt upp.
Åh gud, nej men jag skulle jättegärna vilja göra det.
Jag förstår den grejen verkligen.
Det är ju det man vill att de ska vara till möteskående.
Det är inte alltid så, tyvärr.
Ja, nej det är en egen värld att jobba med producenter och prata på det sättet.
Men i alla fall, jag tycker det är lite intressant.
När man går in på er sajt så är det ju väldigt, det ni säljer är väldigt logiskt.
Men jag gissar att ni, precis som alla andra, hela tiden tänker på att vi ska ta fram det här också, vi ska göra det här också, vi ska gå vidare.
Vad går gränsen?
Hur tänker ni kring sortimentsberättning för att det inte bara ska bli flumma av det?
Nej, det är en bra fråga.
Jag tror att för vår del så handlar det inte om att vi ska ha det från flest produkter, det är inte det som kommer göra att kunden handlar om oss, utan vår del handlar om kvalitet, produktsäkerhet och funktionalitet.
De bitarna är absolut viktigast.
Vi breddade vår sortimenter väldigt mycket i början, vilket jag tror var jätteviktigt som sagt.
Vi tog in pengar och hela den delen, det var en jätteviktig del av vår resa, men nu har det stagnerat lite, och det är för att vi har våra stjärnor i vår produktportrölj.
Om vi ska ta in en ny produkt, så måste det också ha en potential att bli en stjärna.
Vi vill inte ha en massa hillvärmare som bara binder i kapital.
Så jag tror verkligen på att, typ lite the vital few, klart att vi måste ha ett bra sortiment, så att det känns som att vi kan hitta det mest av det viktigaste hos oss, men man behöver liksom inte ha 50 olika muggar, 70 olika flaskor.
Har man en jäkligt bra flaska, då kan du ta fram den i olika färger, olika mönster, men är den riktigt bra?
Då är ju, varför ska du ha tre olika?
Så där drar vi igen sedan.
Och sen också mycket när vi kommer på idéer, eller när vi ser någonting annanstans.
Då går vi alltid tillbaka till våran kärna.
Okej, är det här knatterblock?
Vi har sagt från början att vi är inte det här superfina brandet, som man bara vackert att kolla på, med jätte fina härliga produkter.
Utan vi är funktion, det ska vara funktionellt.
Sen ska det inte vara fult, man vill ändå ha det i sitt hem.
Någon måttar från varandra får säga att...
Men funktionen är viktigast och kan vi inte säga att det här kommer verkligen vara funktionellt, det här kommer att hjälpa barnet eller föräldern, så är det inte en produkt för oss.
Men känner vi att det här kommer verkligen hjälpa och bidra till vår vision och det vi vill göra, då är vi inte sena på bollen heller.
Speciellt inte om det känns som att det är enigt.
Nu är ni inte så...
Vad ska man säga, ni är inte så många år gamla än.
Jag har ju nyligen börjat men...
Men detta känns ju inte som en lokal business, det känns ju som en internationell business.
Men du driver fortfarande kontor på svenska.
Varför liksom?
Är inte det jävligt begränsande?
För personer kan väl inte bry sig om det står på svenska eller engelska?
Men alltså faktiskt, jag tror att...
Som jag sa, en av framgångsfaktorerna har varit att mitt kontor har varit på svenska.
För de svenska följerna.
För att det har funnits på engelska, det får vi inte ha någon konstig kontor när det funnits sådär.
Så jag tror ändå, där det handlar om det här ämnet, barn och mat, så vill många ha det på svenska, även om man kan inte engelska, så tror jag ändå att det är någonting med det här ämnet som vi gör.
Man vill läsa upp svenska, det finns också svenska ryttingar, från till exempel Lyssningsverket och så vidare.
Vi har ju också en jättestor blogg, vi har en jättestor receptbank, vi har ungefär 250 000 besökare varje månad på hemsidan.
Och om man kollar på sån drivlig trafik så är det ju våra recept.
Så det är en jättestor del av det och jag tror att man vill ha recepten på svenska märken.
Men det är klart att vi också tänker på vad vi ska göra sen.
Men det finns så mycket kvar att göra i Sverige och sen så växer vi både i Norge och Finland och då har marknaderna känsligt lättare att ta sig an om en av oss ska välja USA eller någon sån jättemarknad.
Så jag tror att vi ska gräva lite där vi står och verkligen fortsätta i Sverige men också ge oss ut i de nordiska länderna.
Och då har vi pratat om att nu är inte det här någonting som vi har bestämt.
Men vi har pratat om att då skulle man kunna göra ett exempel lokala konton för Norge och Finland.
Vi är ändå ett sociala medierföretag och vi ska fortsätta med det.
Det är det som det är att du vill kunna sätta på oss.
Men då tror jag att vi måste köra lokala sociala medierkonton och sen olika sajter från olika länderna.
Så det vill vi göra men jag tror också att det finns så mycket kvar att göra i Sverige.
Ja, jag tänkte nästan säga.
Svarade du att ni hade 250 000 besökare i månaden?
Ja, det är galet mycket.
Då ville jag nästan, med den snällaste formen av mening, varför är ni inte ännu större?
Vad är det ni missar att sälja?
Helvet, det är ju sjukt mycket folk.
Nej men, jag förstår den frågan.
Jag har ju 170 000 foljare på Instagram.
Många vill ju ha åt recepten.
Det är där vi jobbar jättemycket med.
Vi får in sjukt mycket trafik i våra recept och våra blogg.
Vi jobbar ganska mycket med SGO, så att vi kommer upp.
Om du ställer en fråga om barn och mat på Google så kommer vi upp.
Men det vi jobbar mycket med är att konvertera dem till butiken och där kämpar vi på.
Det är inte att läsa om många som säger att jag ska laga den här muckfingsen och så står de i köket.
Nu kan jag tänka mig att det är så här.
Då står de inte och köper bara muckfingsforum när de står och ska baka det de gör.
Så det är en svår konvertering att göra.
Det gör ju också att kolla på våra siffror så är ju vår konverteringsgrad ganska låg.
Folk går in på hemsidan för att göra annat än att handla.
Det är någonting som vi behöver jobba på och som vi behöver hitta sätt för att göra.
Vi kollar på olika bloggappar och försöker hitta bättre sätt att konvertera.
Jag fick när jag läste om era bolag här, när jag gick in och kollade, som du säger, det driver ju väldigt mycket trafik.
Jag tycker alltid att när folk snackar om att vi ska bygga community, vi ska bygga kunder som bryr sig, det känns alltid så sjukt kryssat.
Vill folk verkligen sitta och snacka om däckstorlek på en bil?
Det känns lite overkill.
Men i just det här fallet så är det verkligen en communitygrej.
Det är klart att folk vill prata om vad deras ungar äter och få tips och råd och sånt där.
Men då tänkte jag, detta måste ju vara det mest klockrena case som någonsin funnits för en större aktör att bara köpa upp och lägga in i sitt bolag för att detta är just en communitydrivare.
Är det något du har tänkt på eller är det något ni har funderat på eller fått propåer om?
Inga propåer än så länge.
Men nej, just nu ser jag inte det som ett alternativ.
Vi har otroligt stora visioner för knäppprock och jag kommer inte släppa det förrän vi har nått det.
Och sen tror jag att vi fortfarande är, jag tror inte många ser vad vi håller på med.
Känner jag lite ibland.
Många kanske inte riktigt ser oss som en aktör att räkna med.
Tror jag inte, i branschen.
Många som följer kanske på efter att se det.
Men jag tror att man möts och knappplockt i den härliga världen med lite recept, lite inspiration, det är liksom Instagram.
Jag tror inte man alltid ser värdet av det faktiskt, om man inte är lite framåt i annan och tänker att vara ett community, görs för affären.
Jag fattar, man ser er nästan som ett, man ser er lite grann som ett Instagramkonto eller en influencer, snarare än ett bolag.
Jag köper hur de tänker, jag fattar det.
Men det kan ju vara lite positivt ett tag.
Jag tror att det har varit en vinnande faktor i det här, att folk, det är lite som misstänksamhet idag mot företag.
Speciellt bra småbarnsvändare.
Många tror att företagen försöker luras, det är det ena med det andra.
Och är man inte ett klassiskt företag, företag, då tror jag att man vinner förtroende lättare.
Ja, men det finns mycket att vinna av det.
Så jag är lite rädd för att vi faktiskt, jag uppfattar oss mer som ett företag.
Och vad det kommer göra med oss som varumärke.
Ja, jag tänkte säga det.
Hur hanterar du den?
När du själv säger att vi blir stora eller vi har stora visioner kring detta, man ser inte riktigt vad vi håller på med.
Om vi även pratar internationellt och sånt där, då måste du bli lite mer corporate.
Om man ska konvertera trafik och sånt där.
Är du inte rädd att du bara bakbinder dig själv, att folk är faktiskt ganska chill med att man tjänar pengar på?
Ibland har man liksom ett hjärnspöke som är sådär att, ja men, folk vill inte köpa detta.
Det är klart folk vill köpa sina barn om det är bra grejer, eller?
Ja, nej men, du slår ju ut sitt huvud på spikern.
Alltså det, men nej, bara om man ska dra så här parallellt med jag och min man då, han är ju lite resan du då.
Han bara vadå, vi kan väl prata om det, det kan vi göra reklam varje dag, får vi knappteplag såhär.
Men alltså jag är såhär, nej nej nej, vi måste hålla det här på jättebra nivå, att det inte får bli så reklamigt, det får inte bli så säljigt och så.
Så att ja, vi är lite motpoler där.
Så jag tycker att det är jättesvår balans, för jag tror att skulle vi liksom bli för säljiga, för reklamiga, då tror jag vi har tappat lite förtroende också.
För att jag tror att vi har ett så stort förtroende idag, för att vi inte bara står och skriker om våra produkter, utan vi pratar snarare om hur vi använder våra produkter, varför vi visar varför de är bra, snarare att berätta varför de är bra.
Det är en hårsin gräns, det där.
Men jag behöver absolut bli mer, vad får man säga, corporate i mitt tänk där.
Men det har jag sagt, vi har ju ett team på Gnatt och Brack nu, och skulle du komma till vårt kontor och prata med oss där, då är det ju absolut corporate.
Där i vårt team så är vi ju otroligt, som ett företag eller organisation är annars.
Men utåtställd så är vi kanske inte det lika mycket som ett annat företag.
Du är ju också lite halvmedial tror jag.
Du har väl varit med i TV någon nyhetsmorgon och liknande ord.
Du syns ju i det här på ditt Instagramkonto.
Är det många som stoppar dig i mataffären och säger va, har du köpt ostbågar?
Eller så vill de ha tips om vad de ska göra.
Känner folk igen dig?
Alltså det beror helt på vart jag är någonstans.
Alltså är jag någonstans där det är mycket småbarns föräldrar.
Då känner folk igen mig och det är inte...
Och sen i Sverige är vi ganska dåliga på att komma fram och prata.
Men jag märker ju att...
Man står och smygdömmer lite från sidan, jag förstår det.
När du skäller ut dina barn på lekplatsen.
Nej jag får passa nu.
Jag märker ju att folk känner igen mig.
Det är ju folk som går fram och så där.
Om man är på en lekplats eller ibland är man akutik och så där.
Men går jag på stan i Stockholm så är det inte så många som kommer fram.
Då är det ju ett annat crowd.
Så det är ändå skönt på ett sätt.
Även fast jag också tycker att det är väldigt roligt när folk kommer fram.
För det är alltingsidigitalt.
Det blir nästan 1-0 när allting är bara i telefonen.
Så det är kul att träffa folk riktigt.
Hur ser du på att bli medial?
För det syns ju både du och det syns dina barn.
Hur tänker du kring balansen där på något sätt?
Jag älskar inte den grejen själv.
Det är ett nödvändigt ont.
Ja, precis.
Jag tycker att det är kul att dela med mig.
Jag tycker att det är kul att vara kreativ.
Jag tycker att det är kul att prata med folk och få en dialog.
Den grejen älskar jag.
Men jag älskar inte att jag som person ska framställas på olika sätt.
Jag vet inte, att det är alltid jag som måste stå och lägga fram i det här bandet som man kan se det som.
Jag gillar inte det riktigt en grejen.
Jag tror inte att jag kommer att vara en ambassadör för knatseprat, men jag kanske inte kommer att vara ansiktigt utåt lika mycket om ett tag beroende på hur vår resa går här.
Jag tänkte säga beroende på hur många barn det blir.
Det finns ju få grejer som bygger mer förtroende och som gör det mer autentiskt än att det är just du.
Och det är dina barn som du testar det på och gör.
Jag kan se att det verkligen bygger varumärket.
Om du helt plötsligt säger, nu syns inte jag längre, nu har vi en annan person här, då blir det ju mer en photoshoot-känsla.
Tråkigt nog, men litegrann är det ju så.
Det där har vi en strategi hur vi ska göra det såklart.
Så det kommer absolut inte kännas.
Så vi ska fortfarande behålla det här mysiga, personliga, eller försöka hela tiden.
Men när det gäller barn så är det ju, alltså min dotter visar jag inte längre.
Hon är ju tre och ett halvt, så att henne känner jag att, nej men hon börjar liksom se ut så som hon kommer se ut resten av livet.
Så jag känner att jag väl liksom inte visar, alltså det är inget hon kan säga det eller säga om hon vill att vi inte är själv.
Min son är ett år och så andas det fortfarande.
Och jag hoppas ändå att de båda kommer känna att de liksom har varit med och bidragit till någonting gott.
För de har ändå hjälpt väldigt många föräldrar där ut att känna sig mer trygga med att ge en plockmat till sina barn eller bara allmänt känna sig mer trygga med maten.
Så jag hoppas att de kommer tänka att det är något härligt och något bra.
Men sen så kommer jag lika gärna med min son sen.
Han är ju inte visad honom heller.
Han får långsamt fäddas ut.
När de blir 18-20 år så kommer det finnas sjuka mängder med tanter och farbröder som går fram och nyper i kinderna och säger jag kände igen dig som liten.
Nej men gud, stacka.
Nej det hoppas jag inte.
Men det kanske är många som har gått och känner igen någon.
Men jag vet inte om man känner igen någon innan de har varit i tre år.
Jag tror att det är rätt lugnt.
Hur säljer ni enbart själva idag eller säljer ni via återförsäljare och liknande?
Vi säljer enbart själva faktiskt.
Vi har valt att inte sälja vi återförsäljare just för att marginalen blir så kass.
Vi har ju så mycket trafikt i hemsidan, där behöver vi egentligen bara även där gräva där vi står.
Ni måste ju ha ett ganska stort problem med att er snittorder är rätt liten.
Det tänker jag är det stora problemet här.
Hur kommer det sig att ni inte jobbar mycket?
För nästan allting säljs i styckvis, ni har nästan inga paket eller bulkgrejer, vilket är rätt konstigt.
Vi kommer att ha nu när julen är igång så kommer vi att göra julklappbundles.
Då kommer det att vara paket, sen brukar det vara paket med servicer.
Men just nu har vi inte dem för att det är trapp från Kina, vi fastnar på olika ställen.
Vi har inte haft så taj lyckan på ett tag.
Så vi vill ta bort dem för att det inte ska ses så jäkla slutsålt.
Ja, verkligen härligt.
Vi brukar ha det bandat och så.
Men vi kan absolut jobba mer med det också.
Men det är det låga snittkvittot är det.
Många ordrar.
Så jag tror att vi har ett tredjepartylager och vi är inte störst i omsättningen de har.
Men vi har jäkla massa ordrar.
Nu på Blackwix är det väl att de får jobba på.
Jag förstår.
Men hur gör ni för att få upp snittkvittot då?
Om ni inte jobbar...
Ni säljer typ inte ens två pakor av grejer.
Nu låter jag jättekritiskt men jag är lite fascinerad.
Vi jobbar med andra saker.
Dels har vi fri frakt över ett visst plopp.
Då får man känna att ligger man nära det här så kanske man lägger in någonting till.
Sen jobbar vi med en appsellapp.
Om man går in på en produkt till exempel så rekommenderar vi andra produkter som du kan lägga till.
För att, köper du en av våra böcker så är det härligt att köpa en nybörjarsked när man ska börja äta.
Vi gör sådana saker.
Vi har inte så mycket paket men däremot andra mekanismer för att få nya snittkortot.
Under julen till exempel, där kommer vi att ha en receptfolder.
Där köper man över ett visst belopp så kommer man att få med sig en folder med olika julrecept.
Det har vi jobbat med tidigare också, med olika folderar, olika recept och olika sådana saker.
Vi har nästan aldrig rabatter på hemsidan om ni inte är ett black-and-white nu då.
Utan vi jobbar hellre med att man får något extra om man köper någonting.
Jag köper det.
Vad har varit, det är ju en väldigt snabb tillväxt, och det är en väldigt snabb resa som ni har gjort.
Det gör ju att saker onekligen kommer att bli eftertjat, eller man kommer att upptäcka typ att fan vi omsätter åtta miljoner men vi har typ inte det här.
Man upptäcker ju grejer som om man gör en långsammare resa så upptäcker man det på vägen för man tänker på det mer.
Men här, jag bara gissar, för det låter så på det, att er största problem har hela tiden bara fått hemvaror och få ut dem, det låter som det.
Då blir det ju många andra problem eftertjatta men nu när du, kanske inte under Black Week men nu när du får titta tillbaka lite och stanna upp lite, vad är liksom de stora problemen eller punkterna som är eftertjatta som du känner att ska vi upp till 50 miljoner då måste vi fan lösa det där.
Oj ja, bra fråga.
Nej men alltså vi har som du säger, vi har ett problem med vår logistik, hur vi går lagerhållning, inköp, alltså allt det där.
Det är inget väl smort maskin i.
Där måste du verkligen hitta någon bra balans för att inte binda kapital men samtidigt inte handla om att bli slutsående hela tiden, vilket gör att vi inte når ut till vår fulla potential när vi inte har lager liksom.
Vi är skitstörd.
I år kommer vi att ha en dubbla omsättning igen och vi hade antalet tyckte om vi hade haft lager.
Så det är ett problem.
Sen som vi var inne på, konverteringen från receptsidan till hemsidan, också en grej vi måste jobba åt mycket.
Sen har vi också några saker som vi behöver.
Vår marknadsföringstrategi har också varit lite såhär, vi har förlittat oss väldigt mycket på det organiska, vilket har varit superlyxigt, via knatter av Instagram.
Det har varit superlyxigt att vi har en gratis kanal med 170 000 personer som gärna lyssnar på vad jag har att säga.
Det är guld värt och det har vi förlittat oss på väldigt mycket och det har funkat väldigt bra.
Men vi måste ju också vara utanför det.
Det har vi jobbat med väldigt mycket senare i tiden.
Hur vi ska göra och hur vi ska nå det kalla publiken.
Där behöver vi fortsätta jobba och fortsätta ta fram strategier och planer med det så att vi går bortom Instagram.
Ni jobbar ingenting med YouTube och liknande?
Nej, inte YouTube.
Jag bara tänker titta på när ni står och lagar recept och sen hur det funkar.
Det känns så klockrent på något sätt.
Ja, jag vill ju starta upp en till kanal, men sen vet jag inte om det ska bli TikTok eller YouTube eller vad det ska bli.
Just mat på YouTube är väldigt hårt.
Det är få matkreatörer som lyckas på YouTube faktiskt.
Jag var på en lunch med Media Akademin som ger ut en årets makthavare en lista.
De pratar om att YouTube är jättetårt när det gäller mat.
Jag lutar för att det kanske är TikTok.
Jag har inte ens TikTok själv.
Det är ganska uppförspakigt för mig.
Men jag tror att vi kommer att ha den växt i teamet och då får någon råda TikTok.
Det är ett smidigt sätt att lämna över det.
Vad blir din stora roll i företaget här framöver?
Jag hoppas att min roll, just nu är ju väldigt mycket content-treatör och lite vd.
Är det det du vill vara?
Ja, delvis.
Jag tycker att det är väldigt roligt.
Jag vill ju inte att det ska ta upp 80% av min tid.
Utan jag vill ju vara vd och leda företaget och göra alla vd-nats, men inte hinna göra som vd idag.
Så jag hoppas att jag framöver kan fortsätta jobba med recept och vara kreatör men inte så mycket som jag nu.
Vi ska försöka forma om det lite så att det tar in andra inklag som inte kräver så mycket av mig.
Är det även du som sitter med produktutveckling och liknande?
Eller var det din kollega där?
Nej, jag sitter mycket med produktutveckling.
Jag är nog insett där i det mesta.
Det är inte heller hållbart på sikt.
Men produktutveckling är också något jag brinner för så du tror inte jag kommer att släppa.
Så du ska ha contentutveckling och produktutveckling men du vill hinna med lite vd-grejer också på sidan av där.
Ja men fullt rimligt.
Det är väl rimligt.
Vad är det du vill släppa?
Nu ser inte folk som lyssnar här men det är en hund som håller på att hoppa runt på ditt skrivbord här samtidigt.
Hon vill vara med.
Som alltid.
Nej men det låter väl helt rimligt.
Nej det är ju inte det.
Jag har inga intressade, jag har inget fritid.
Jag är med mina barn och jobbar ungefär så.
Och det håller jag bort på sikt inser jag.
Men jag kommer att göra mycket mindre av content och lite mindre av produktutveckling och försöka vara ännu mer vd ju större bolaget blir.
Men när vi är ett litet team så är vd-rollen inte sådär jättekrävande i sig, men jag tror att den kommer att bli det på sikt.
Så då får det väl bli en naturlig övergång.
Sen hoppas jag på.
Vad kommer inspirationen ifrån?
Både till produkter men även till hela den här receptbanken, eller vad vi ska se i hela contentmaterialet.
Ja, bra fråga.
Min hjärna går nog på högvaro hela tiden tror jag.
Jag tar någon inspiration från allt möjligt som jag ser.
Mycket på sociala medier så pratar man om att man ser någonting, jag kan se en vuxenversion av en kaka säger vi, och då, åh det här borde man kunna göra en barnversion på som är lite mer näringsrik.
Eller så ser jag någonting annat på stan eller så där.
Men det är svårt att säga.
Mycket Pinterest kollar jag på.
Mycket så här, jag tycker amerikanska kontor är faktiskt lite bra och härligt att kolla på för de är oftast lite längre fram.
Där kollar jag också, till exempel vår nivåsked som är en av våra stora säljare.
Vår Prespoon som heter.
Det är en sked som små bebisar kan använda själv lite lättare än en vanlig ekped.
Den fanns inte i Sverige.
Men jag såg att den användes mycket i USA och tänkte att den här måste vi kunna göra någonting av själva.
Ja, det är en svår fråga.
Vad hämtar man inspiration?
Man ser lite saker överallt helt enkelt och gärna processar och sådant så kommer det ut fler produkter eller lite idéer.
Det är en spännande, det är liksom en, på något sätt så, det är inte så vanligt den här affärsmodellen som ni har haft utan ni behöver kanske, som du säger, inte marknadsföra er själva så mycket utan ni har ju gått via ett ganska organiskt flöde och ni fick in investerare ganska tidigt och ni lyckades sälja slut på grejer vilket ju är ett lyxproblem, även om jag förstår att du är irriterad på det, så är det ju ett lyxproblem.
Dessutom är ju hela bebisbranschen lite i kris, alla bebisbolag går ju skit liksom, förutom några instakare.
Så det är en väldigt spännande resa.
Är det bara att ni har en, ni ligger bara helt rätt i produkt liksom?
Ja, jag tror att det är en väldigt bra, en klassisk product market pick.
Jag tror att det, men också en timingfråga också.
När kontot kom så var det ju såhär, många började ge mig plockmat, många sökte inspiration kring barn och mat generellt och det fanns inte så mycket.
Vi byggde upp ett förtroende där tidigt, så när vi lanserade produkter så hade vi ett jättebra förtroende redan från kunderna.
Och jag tror att det är det som har gjort att det har gått så pass bra och sen att vi har egna produkter.
De babyföretagare som kallar oss och går dåligt nu är ofta stads-
och andra varumärken.
Där blir det priskriget hela tiden.
Vi är de enda som har våra produkter.
Så jag tror att det är en viktig faktor i det också.
Att vi har positionerat oss, att vi har nischat oss.
Vi är produktionella produkter som stödjer barns självständiga akande.
Det låter ju såhär super nischat, men det finns en jättestor kundgrupp för det.
Och där är vi helt klart bäst på just den grejen.
Är det den som kommer fortsätta vara den stora?
För att ni har ju ett litet problem i att era kunder växer upp.
Det är inte så att era kundgrupp stannar kvar i 20 år förhoppningsvis.
Och gissningsvis, jag får känslan att ni inte heller vill att sakerna ska gå sönder efter ett halvår.
Så då kanske man ger vidare dem till sin syster eller sin brorskär eller vad som helst.
Hur ser du på att kundgruppen är stängd?
Det fälls ju nya barn hela tiden, det är det positiva med det här kundgruppen.
Men sedan också i taktband med att innan barn blir äldre eller min dotter så har vi också andra sorters produkter som passar äldre barn också.
Så eftersom jag också bryr mig för mycket när det är barns matglädje och så, så har vi ju till exempel att ha lite sådana produkter som inkluderar barnen i köket.
Till exempel barnanpassade köksknivar.
Allting handlar inte bara om att flykta till bebis utan vi har även produkter till äldre barn även om att passivåran tyngdpunkt såklart ligger.
Kanske det första året eller första par i åren.
Men vi har ju typ 35 procent återkommande kunder.
Så folk kommer ju tillbaka på valgen.
Nu är det kul för att nu är det många som kommer tillbaka med andra barnet som kanske följer mig.
För när jag fick min dotter och så kommer det andra barn.
Ja men jag följde till sin poäng, nu ska jag fylla på någonting eller köpa det här som jag kommer till mig senast.
Så det är jätteroligt.
Jättespännande.
Sjukt bra business.
Nu har ni ju stängt er en sådan här investerar grej men även om ni inte alls har någonting med gymutrustningar.
Jag blir såhär, fan det här är en bra idé.
Det här önskar jag att jag hade kommit in i.
Här vill jag vara med.
Men det tror jag fler människor tänker.
Det är ju en jäkla fin.
Det känns som att ni har så mycket kvar att göra.
Och jag menar det på ett gott sätt.
Jag menar att det känns som att det finns mycket lågt hängande frukt som liksom inte är på plats riktigt ändå.
När man gör det så blir det ännu bättre.
Så det är jättespännande.
Ja, men det är kul.
Jag lovar att jag kontaktar dig om det.
Skitbehöverpengar.
Nej men det är jättekul.
Vårt mål är att bygga en svär, en knatterprock-svär.
Där webbshoppar är bara en del av det.
Vi vill göra massa olika saker.
Vi har ju böcker, jag har haft en podd, vi har ju bara sett bank.
Allt det där hänger ihop, inom en strax.
Ja, klättsprock-svär som bara ska hjälpa föräldrar och barn.
Så det finns jättemycket att göra i den delen.
Lycka till i framsidan.
Vi säger tack så jättemycket för att du var med i podden.
Tack så mycket.
Vill folk verkligen sitta och snacka om däckstorlek på en bil?
Det känns lite overkill.